[Music]
good evening everybody i'm jesse weber
and welcome to prime crime tonight
this is where we do a deeper dive into
the most high profile and memorable
true crime cases tonight a death link to
a missing woman
a dismemberment and a high-profile real
estate error
my next-door neighbor one of our other
neighbors um
found her dog on the street yesterday
and um
oh no no we have her the problem is um
faith gave us the dog and we went over
next door to see
if susan was home and her car's in the
driveway
she's not absolutely her door they're
packing on our doorstep
she's not answering her phone her doctor
is wide open
so i don't know what's going on on
december 24
2000 los angeles police entered the
residence of 1527
benedict canyon and discovered the body
of 55 year old susan berman
shot in the back of the head almost 15
years after her death in 2015
authorities arrested her longtime friend
robert
allen durst the heir to a family real
estate empire reportedly valued
at 4.4 billion dollars one of the most
important pieces of evidence comes from
robert durst's possibly oddest move
his decision to sit down for an almost
three hour interview with los
angeles deputy district attorney john
lewin the man who would become the lead
prosecutor in his trial for the murder
of susan berman
he just has diary of the mountain he
just can't stop
talking about these events and it seems
that in some way he feels the need to
justify his actions why why he was on
the run
what happened with all these people who
continuously
seem to die around him well let's rewind
for a second in order to understand why
durst would have killed susan berman we
have to go back to his marriage to
kathleen
mccormick durst the former med student
and wife of robert durst
disappeared on january 31 1982
and her body has never been found she
was afraid of him but at the same time
was a dichotomy where if she had a
couple of drinks in her she got
stronger because i was basically saying
get the heck out and she was afraid but
she thought she could handle them
even though durst claims he got into an
argument with his former wife and may
have been the last person to see her
alive
he's never been criminally charged in
connection with kathleen's case
prosecutors allege though he killed her
especially since
she may have been seeking a pricey
divorce
kathy felt like
somebody i don't know who my redeski
alberta
told kathy that if she
could prove that that i've been beating
her up
she would get a bigger settlement
so kathy started doing these things
to start fights and she would walk
around
rubbing this and then go tell a friend
look what he did to me and stuff like
that
well you know she didn't want me to win
maybe she accepted that i was going to
be get a divorce if i wanted to get a
divorce
but she didn't want me
she didn't want it to look like i came
away the winner
the problem is without a body or really
any physical evidence
we don't know exactly what happened fast
forward to 2000 the investigation into
kathleen's disappearance is reopened
and it would soon involve a new player
susan berman
journalist susan berman and robert durst
developed a close
deep friendship with prosecutors
alleging that not only did durst confide
in berman that he killed his wife
but she helped him with an alibi namely
posing as kathleen
and calling in sick to work i don't
think abby called
i know do you know who i think and i'm
not asking you
what happened but do you know who i
think called any guesses
movie and andrew was going through the
opinion it was seriously verbal
yeah and and i i wanna i want to ask you
something
and again we're not talking about what
actually happened
but let's say you would have come to
susan
okay she would have said no she would
have said no she would not have
risked her life for something
like that so if berman was such a good
friend as to help durst get away with
murder
why would he kill her because guess who
durst thought police wanted to speak to
about kathleen
susan told me that she'd been contacted
by
los angeles detectives and new york
detectives
and they want to come talk to me and
and and if i asked you on a scale of one
to a hundred
with one being i'm not sure she said it
and a hundred being on positive
you would say that that susan told you
that
susan definitely told me she's been
contacted by that
i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you something
that wasn't true they had not contacted
her
the fact that he was surprised would
tend to
uh lead me to believe that susan was
rather adamant about the fact that she
was going to go to the police
and then what's the natural conclusion
that he feared that
and that was the motive for the murder
so if the prosecutors are able to
connect the dots for
the jury the fact that he was surprised
and you know connect that to the motive
that could be quite damning
it was very interesting that he was
surprised that she never contacted them
it was kind of a oops moment so to speak
but motive even one possibly based on an
incorrect assumption
is not enough what prosecutors need is
evidence
but in this case no dna fingerprints
hair fibers blood or eyewitnesses
directly link durst
to burman shooting the absence of
physical proof though
may itself be a clue i think it is
strange that there wasn't
a lot of physical evidence on the crime
scene we've got a shell casing a nine
millimeter casing
we have a door that's been open uh we
believe it was opened by susan there was
no force entry so that's kind of the
reason we believe that she knew
who she was opening the door for and
that it was quick
there was a job that was done it
appeared to be execution style
and the fact that it was an in and out
so not a lot of time to leave evidence
then there's the matter of durst
whereabouts at the time investigators
say
durst may have traveled from northern
california to l.a to kill berman
john lewin pressed durst on why he
bought a ticket for a red-eye flight
from san francisco
and at the counter activities that durst
never really did
what were you doing that made you get
down to san francisco
and why just doesn't make sense
i was just trying to understand that
yeah yeah yeah i hear you
i hear you i'm just not going to be able
to answer that because i just
okay okay that's listen that's fair um
but but you agree it it's hard
predictable behavior with robert durst
in planning
to see susan berman to actually book a
flight
but to not book a flight directly to la
when she lived in beverly hills
to go to san francisco and then to get
out of town as fast as he could by
driving
durst lawyers would later argue that he
did visit berman
and that in fact it's his defense bob
durst
did not kill susan berman and he doesn't
know who did
he did find her body he was coming to
visit her
for the christmas holidays the only
problem with that
is he didn't quite say the same thing to
john lewin
what i'm telling you is i'm just saying
that did not happen
you agree you did not just find susan's
body
and somebody else killed her did not
find jose's body
okay this is a pattern this is an
absolute pattern
the defense is basically cleaning up
all the statements that durst made to
lewin
there's a list of statements he made i
think they see which ones were damning
and
they see an opportunity here to recant
some of that testimony after berman's
death police receive a letter postmarked
december 23rd
the day before police found berman's
body it's imprinted with her address and
the word cadaver
the handwriting arguably matches that of
a letter durce wrote to berman
particularly the misspelling of beverly
durst was asked about the note
you agree as you sit here today you
agree
that whoever wrote that letter they
killed susan
agree i don't know that i mean
maybe there were two people who killed
the suicide
okay it doesn't have to be one person
there could be two
people one people one person could go
into the house to shoot susan and the
other person could
be the driver oh okay no let me let me
this what i mean
whether the person was the shooter or
the driver whoever wrote the note
was a part of killing her yes
you agree right yes no question right
whoever wrote that note had to be
involved in susan's death
okay despite repeatedly denying being
the author
in a shocking turn of events durst
lawyers would concede that the real
estate scion
did write the letter the only evidence
is the note
a note written by bob to direct the
police to her body
i can't understand a strategy of
reversing
um that admission or lack thereof
unless a they knew for a fact that gonna
be some
overwhelming evidence that would point
the finger to their client whereby the
jury would see that he was lying
or b your client himself actually
want to admit that he wrote the note
this might have been
his way of establishing a connection
to the police uh because once again he
needs to have those relationships
those relationships so writing this
letter was probably the
first step in creating that relationship
with law enforcement
and the fact that he said in his
interview with john lewin
that he preferred dogs over people three
dogs were in that home he had a
relationship with those dogs over the
years
so it also could have been the fact that
he knew that those dogs would not be
tended to
during that time and have the police get
there sooner when we come back we're
going to focus on the next
chapter of the durs saga he goes to
texas to seemingly escape the attention
in new york
but his plans soon turn deadly being a
fugitive
was not something i did well
[Music]
if you had killed kathy
would you tell me okay
you know what i pretty if you had killed
susan would you tell me
after the disappearance of his wife
kathleen and the death of his longtime
friend susan berman real estate air
robert durst finds himself down in texas
now if the goal was for him to lay low
and escape the media attention
things couldn't have gone worse
investigators believe
durst went into hiding in galveston
texas by posing
and even dressing as a woman but they
say one man
figured out durst's identity his 71 year
old neighbor
morris black what do police say durst
did
that he murdered and dismembered him the
father and son
were fishing on galveston island and
there were
several trash bags that they found
floating in the water that were
each contained a body part there was a
severed leg
another severed leg severed arms that
were in separate
packages and then there was the torso
but there was no head
in his explosive trial in 2003 for the
murder of morris black
durst took the stand and claimed he shot
and killed his neighbor in self-defense
but admitted he did chop up the body in
a state of panic
by using knives saws and an axe
dismembering someone is a is a
physically and emotionally
challenging behavior um
the person has to have an intense amount
of
physical strength in order to accomplish
that task but they also have to have an
emotional strength
where the idea that you're cutting off
limbs of a person and you are the
you are the hands that are doing it
plays a heavy toll
on someone and so what i would say is
that it is
unlikely that this was the first time
he had ever engaged in some kind of
dismembering
whether it's dismembering of an animal
as a child or something like that
in order to to truly accomplish the goal
the jury would acquit
durst of the murder of black but
whatever reason the jury really
bought this and it's rather interesting
and i think it goes to the fact
that why durst keeps talking uh
he is somewhat persuasive and he's a
compelling figure
and i think the jury just bought into
basically his
argument and perhaps that's why we see
the behavior
in him that we see now some say the
morris black case though
may provide insight into what happened
to kathleen durst and that presuming
robert durst is the killer
he may have dismembered and discarded
her body as well
picking somebody up with a saw is a
really difficult thing to do i agree
and and and you've done that now
twice correct i'm not gonna go there
okay okay okay all right
one okay okay i gotta ask um
uh you were able
if you you know that the way the body
was cut
somebody knew how to cut the joints you
see i don't
know that subsequently i've been told
um that a surgeon would
cut up a body the same way you you
do a chicken you go into the joint and
you cut around the joint to get rid of
all the ligaments and then the thing
comes out you're not going to go and try
to cut through the goddamn
bone like i did which was hard
um well you you did a you did a pretty
good job
the the thing that that cutting through
a bone is not easy with anything
john lewin wouldn't be the only person
to question durst
prior to his arrest the eccentric
millionaire sat down for a series of
interviews for an hbo special called the
jinx
produced by andrew jarrecki the director
of the movie all good things
which itself was a dramatization of
durst's life
the jinx would become a piece of
critical evidence
in the finale durst allegedly confesses
over a hot mic
while in the bathroom
of course
but durst legal team says the recording
was manipulated and his words
reorganized
which is arguably supported by the
release of the full audio transcript
it's a reach to think that it was
manipulated to put
words in his mouth the big point here
is that he did so voluntarily so it's
evidence that will be weighed and a jury
will certainly have an opportunity to
either believe
the evidence or disbelieve the evidence
however
he you know these words came out of his
mouth
i think in a moment of privacy when he's
in the bathroom i think it's probably
most likely normal behavior a normal
internal dialogue
that he was having with himself playing
out both sides of
did should i reveal this should i not
reveal this
durst said he agreed to the interviews
to hopefully come off more sympathetic
but the jinx seemed to hurt him more
than it helped
maybe he had a reason for the things he
said for the whole
long weekend when i did the interviews
for the jinx
yeah i was on some mess the whole time i
was on a mess
and when i looked at the little pieces
of it i was
surprised my lawyer let me go ahead with
it because it just
i looked like there was something going
on
well so bob is is that a way of you
of you saying that the things you that
you said during that interview
um you didn't understand questions or
you weren't getting it because bob
bob because before you go any further on
that
certain things i know and you seem like
a straight shooter i assume
you would prefer that i'd be a straight
shooter and not a bullshit right
sure okay i'm a straight shooter what
you just told me
is bullshit you were i've watched those
interviews
i don't know why you did it i still
don't explain i know your lawyers didn't
want you to do it
no they didn't know them and they told
you they didn't want you to do it
repeatedly
repeat it and and you did it anyway over
the course of durst's discussion with
the government and the producers of the
jinx
there were times when it appeared durst
knew a lot more than he was letting on
one of those moments came at a critical
point in his conversation with lewin
what what's going through my mind is
if i tell you what i know
okay that answers your questions what
can you
possibly do for me okay let me i'll
i'll tell you what if you are willing
to speak to me when you get back from
court we can talk about that
and i can i can tell you um i can tell
you bob i'm very willing to talk to you
and as i said i'm 72.
if if i go ahead with what my lawyers
are telling me
and fight with you and let's say i win
then i'm two years later
74 with a couple of years
bob i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you
something right now
you're not going to win it seemed pretty
clear that dirtz was fishing
for a deal in his interview with john
lewin and that is
wildly interesting because it is uh not
too often
that folks who truly believe themselves
innocent
will fish for a deal now it is possible
given his relative age and he seems to
be in poor health maybe he's just tired
of the
entire thing however the same thing
could be true if he
actually committed these crimes he's
been on the run he's
been involved in some way shape or form
the deaths of several people and perhaps
he's just tired
and wants it to go away and rather live
out the rest of his life
in prison ultimately it will be a jury
who will go through the evidence to
decide the fate of robert durst
at the time of this recording his trial
in la for the murder of susan berman had
been stopped after a few days and
postponed
due to the coven 19 pandemic wall's
defense feels strongly that their client
is innocent
but are considered underdogs i've always
been like that even as a kid i always
stood up for the underdog
comfortable like they did once before in
galveston that the jury's going to know
that mr durst is not anything but
a fellow who i think has been persecuted
and has been
targeted others believe durst is right
where he belongs
answering for many of the evils in his
life
he either doesn't care that he's going
to be the primary suspect in
in each of these crimes or he doesn't he
does know
and just doesn't think that anything
really bad is gonna happen and if that's
the case
i think it's probably again another
piece of
evidence when it comes to his borderline
personality traits
these people somehow offended him in
some way
at first they were appropriate for him
to have in his life but the moment that
he thought that they
that they weren't good enough then he
just needed to cut them out completely
and for him it probably meant
the the ending of their lives robert
durst uh
the man he's a complicated individual
clearly uh has some emotional
issues going on now the former
law enforcement investigator in me law
enforcement detective
too many bodies around robert durst too
many people die
and where there's smoke there's fire in
the end the question is
is robert durst constantly in the wrong
place at the wrong time
just a victim of circumstance or is he
really a vicious killer
who's been covering up one crime after
another
trying to predict what will ultimately
happen to robert durst
may prove as difficult as trying to
understand his past
that's all we have for you on prime
crime tonight give us your comments on
robert durst on twitter and facebook
with the hashtag primecrimetonight
thank you for joining us and until next
time be safe
[Music]
[Music]
you